[Music]
chuck it's that time again
yes it is explainer video
and so for today we have a topic that
falls
outside of my expertise okay i i enjoy
thinking about this subject but i don't
i don't know
i don't know enough about it to be being
the explainer
so we're gonna talk about volcanoes and
with the question
is yellowstone gonna blow
that's the question okay right and so we
need a we need a volcanologist for this
all right and so we found one okay okay
in the name of janine krippner janine
welcome to star talk
thank you for having me excellent and
you work for the smithsonian global
vulcanism program
and i'm glad people are thinking about
volcanoes worldwide because they're all
over the place
okay so janine what is
yellowstone is in the news anytime
someone wants to think apocalyptically
so and we've all been told and we've all
heard it's a super volcano
what is a super volcano super volcano is
basically a name that was made up for a
volcano that has at some point in the
past produced the largest
style of eruption that does not mean
it's going to do it again
it does not mean that every eruption is
that big in fact most eruptions are much
much smaller
so it's kind of a term that basically is
the monster under the bed
of volcanoes of the current age okay so
when you say a big
eruption do you speak a volume of
ash that comes out or and or so what's
what's a typical volume
for a super volcano to be called a super
volcano
so for these super eruptions or we have
this volcano explosivity index
vei so it goes from one or there is
smaller as well but for this
one to eight eight is this super
eruption where
why doesn't it go to ten what do you get
what's wrong with eight
okay okay i'm a 10 chauvinist i'm sorry
well it's looking at volume i'm gonna
say
never in my life have i been asked on a
scale of one to eight
how do you feel about no one has ever
done that ever
okay ever ever well you're missing out
okay all right hang out with more
volcanologists i'm actually gonna i'm
gonna use that now thank you
let's go one to eight of yellowstone
being eight and and
walk in the parking one where is 2020
so a vi8 or these super eruptions
are um you're looking at a volume of
magma erupting that's around a thousand
cubic kilometers so a lot of rock coming
out of the ground
kilometers so a thousand if you take the
cube root you get how big a cube would
be on the side
so 10 kilometers on a side so
for the american audience that you've
heard of 10k runs that's about 6 miles
so imagine a cube 6
miles across deep and high
and that's how much lava came out
that's crazy that's yeah yeah
so luckily for us it's very very hard to
get that amount of magma out of the
ground
in fact to accumulate that much magma in
one place
where it's an eruptable state is very
very difficult and takes a long time
so we all know based on every tabloid
headline out there in yellowstone that
there is this big magma reservoir under
the volcano
but less than 15 of it is actually
liquid a lot of it is
crystals and solid rock so it's kind of
locked up in the system
you need at least 30 ish for that to
erupt
so there's not even enough liquid um
eruptable magma as far as we know
under yellowstone for it to produce the
style of corruption well wait so
does yellowstone is there a crater rim
to that
because i visited it a couple of years
ago and you're just there
you know there's a hot spring here and a
singed tree there
and i'm not thinking i'm in the middle
of a volcanic crater
but you're telling me it is a crater
it's just way bigger than i could see in
that moment
so it's a caldera so a crater is
generally a hole in the ground
formed during an eruption so you have a
lot of stuff coming out of the volcano
a caldera goes the other way that's when
you have so much magma erupting that the
ground actually collapses in on itself
i don't know yeah and we've had a few
recent ones in fact there was caldera
collapsed in 2018 at kilauea
so they're not always explosive they're
not always these big catastrophic events
they can be slow
um but with these vi8 eruptions they are
very catastrophic very very explosive
they can produce
ash over 40 kilometers up into the air
um and it can cause a few years at least
of global cooling as well um
but so if you go 40 kilometers up now
you're in like the jet stream
and you can easily wrap the earth if you
if you get that high up
you still have a local weather it's like
global yeah i mean
a lot of the heavier stuff because this
is solid rock that's coming out this
isn't like your ash that you get out of
fireplace
solid rocks a lot of the heavier stuff
is going to fall out
within kilometers of the volcano um but
you can still get very fine glass
and we saw this with the af 2010
eruption
which the ash came out of iceland and
moved its way over europe and closed the
airspaces because it's not safe to fly
through this stuff
so it would be devastating yeah i do
think actually that is my professional
opinion
don't fly through the volcanic clones
fly through an interruption
um we've also been doing a lot more
research on how much like how much do
you need in the atmosphere for it to be
dangerous
since that eruption so there's a lot
more understanding of what you can fly
through
um or how high or low you have to be to
avoid it um and and and how exactly are
you getting the uh
the empirical results who's who's
testing this flying by flying through it
there was actually someone there who
flew through volcanic ash to test it out
wow god so that's just you can get a jet
engine and put it in the lab
as well that's probably uh yeah that
would be the chuck nice way instead of
the super dave
osborne way of actually flying through
volcanic
eruptions that's crazy all right so
so uh not to put words in your mouth but
you're saying we're overreacting in our
storytelling
about the risks of yellowstone if it
happened
which at this point there is no evidence
that is going to
any time zone and by any time soon i'm
saying hundreds of years at least
um it would be horrible
in every sense of that word but it is
very unlikely to happen
in fact over the last 50 eruptions of
yellowstone
most of them have been much smaller have
been lava flows
so yes almost everything you read in the
news about yellowstone is an
exaggeration
so clickbait clickbait
clickbait so i think what you said was
particularly
damning of those of those suggestions
when you said
it's one thing to have a place where it
could happen but
you have to gather the magma it's got to
all be liquid
and it's got to be able to punch through
and if you don't it's a checklist
basically right if you don't satisfy
this checklist
go home you know go study another
volcano
yep yeah so i don't study it i'm saying
volcanoes that are more likely to erupt
at this stage
but if you look at it right i don't i
don't have time for the do nothing
i don't have time for that i'm sorry
okay
i have to spend my time she did not do
this with her head while she said
i need i need time to see what's
happening stuff that's actually
happening yeah a little more active
like less than more than much more
recent than 70 000 years ago thank you
i let the i let the old volcanologists
deal with yellowstone
i need some action yes exactly i mean
there are great volcanologists studying
this volcano and doing incredible work
just not my area we can't study
everything
in one time so if i can broaden this
just a little bit
um there were other super volcanoes in
the history
of the fossil record um one of them i
learned about from my
from my dinosaur colleagues the deccan
traps
in india i think they were known to have
exploded 65 million years ago about
when we lost the big dinosaurs so
here we have a case where holding aside
the asteroid that
i i got an asteroid i gave you 65
million years ago
was that not enough to kill your
dinosaurs but they're invoking a super
volcano
so as darkening the earth and possibly
affecting the food chain
so you would agree that a modern super
volcano would have
would be as devastating is that correct
no that's not a super volcano that's
actually something entirely different
so those very large um flood basalt
volcanoes
they they they occur over millions of
years
first of all they produce a lot of very
runny lava um
and they've generally got smaller over
time and we don't know that another one
will it's an official term runny lava
it is today okay okay low viscosity
low viscosity
very runny um and they go over enormous
distances
and there have been multiple of them so
the columbia river basalts over in
washington and oregon is a more local
example for
america um and those who are repaving a
whole area
of earth's surface yes and tens to
hundreds of meters of
stacked lava flows over millions of
years so it's not just one event whereas
a super eruption is one event
much more explosive much stickier or
more viscous
lavas as well so different lava type
altogether much shorter event
still devastating but those big flood
basalts those are
much worse okay so people thinking that
the yellowstone is ready to go at any
time makes great story fodder
and janine a volcanologist says no
no and go to the yellowstone volcano
observatory it's not just
the united states geological survey you
know there are trust issues with
government everywhere in the world
it's a group of different organizations
that are monitoring this volcano
plus if this volcano was going to
produce something big
you could not hide the signs even if you
wanted to and as volcanologists we never
do
we want to help people that's what we do
we're trying to warn people
and keep people safe but if for some
non-existent reason people wanted
to hide this you couldn't there would be
a lot of warning
um to get that magma moving towards the
surface this was really sticky
solid like magma there are going to be a
lot of signs there's going to be a lot
of
gas emissions a lot of earthquake it's
going to break a lot of
ground going through not to say that
earthquakes mean a volcanic rupture is
going to happen
there's also a tectonically tectonically
active area
um and it'd also be deformation there is
normal
definite deformation in that area too
but it'd be much more significant you'd
see
increasing activity around the park over
a large area
you couldn't hide that so janine the the
corresponding
example of that in my field is if you
looked at the film
armageddon and so apparently the
government found an asteroid the size of
texas headed towards earth
and kept it a secret from people you
can't keep the sky a secret
people we have telescopes we can look up
okay i can find that
and it is not something the government
can keep as a secret yeah and why would
you want to
and you need to so but the the story
needs it
because you don't want to be able to
trust the government but anyhow janine
we gotta we gotta sort of
bring this [ __ ] you knew to a thought
you knew to a close
um give us some something someone is
thinking about
being a scientist tell us why they
should be a volcanologist
if you love volcanoes that's the thing
to do it's very difficult career like
any
career that needs a phd and experience
but it is
it's an incredible field i absolutely
love what i do
it's you know whatever you want to do
whether it's volcanoes whether it's
space or there's art
whether it's singing whether it's comedy
you know if that's what really makes
your heart sing go for it
if it's hard it's going to be hard
anyway you may as well be doing
something you like
i'm going to disagree with the comedy
don't do that please
don't ruin your life don't ruin your
life don't ruin your life you don't want
to do it
let me ask you this if you could have a
saying for if volcanologists had like
the army they used to have those
commercials
we do more before 6 a.m than
most people do all day which is why i
didn't join the army
because that just sounds like really
hard like they're they should have gone
with you know
we sleep until 12 and then we have
pancakes i'm like oh sign me up
sign me up um i bet you're so gg what's
your tag
what would the tagline for a
volcanologist be uh maybe
earth we're watching you oh oh
look at you all right you know that's
hot okay
right off i like that i like it very
nice very nice well jenny you say hot
because magma like
of course i did but you know i didn't
want you to point it out
see what you did there
oh by the way there are volcanoes on
some of the moons of
jupiter and saturn except they're ice
volcanoes
so having volcanoes not a matter of
being hot it's a matter of how much
pressure is there
you're gonna have pressure at any
temperature smoking like a true neil
degrasse tyson i love you i thought i
put that in
all right we gotta end it there janine
great to have you thanks for
sharing your expertise chuck always good
to have you
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
signing off